الهالوين مهم جدًا
لمارس ريجلي ، إنه الموسم الأول لدينا
وهو موسم ثمانية وثمانية مليارات دولار
لتجار التجزئة لدينا ، بدأنا في
الاستعداد لعيد الهالوين
بعد عامين من أحد الأشياء التي
تغيرت حقًا هو أن البالغين
يشاركون كثيرًا  مستوى أعلى
على مدار العامين الماضيين ، شهدنا زيادة بنسبة 45 في
المائة في مشاركة البالغين ،
وهناك أيضًا اتجاهان آخران ، لقد
أصبح بالفعل موسمًا مدته 8 أسابيع
ونرى ذلك يحدث على ثلاث مراحل حيث
يفكر الأشخاص في فصل الخريف
الخبز ، لذلك هناك عنصر الخبز
ثم ينتقل إلى وقت الاحتفال
حيث يكون لديك تلك
الحفلات المجاورة وأخيرًا وليس آخرًا ، إنها
خدعة أو حلوى حيث
تأتي غالبية مبيعاتنا من أحد
أكبر الاتجاهات لدينا  شوهد على مدى السنوات
الخمس الماضية رغبة المستهلكين في
إنفاق المزيد حيث كانت الحقيبة التقليدية
ربما تكون حقيبة متوسطة الحجم تشاهد
المستهلكين يشترون 60 أونصة 80
أونصة أكياس 100 أونصة من المنتج  ause it يمنح
المستهلكين المتنوعين يحبون متنوعًا
يأتي المستهلكون للبحث عن العناصر المفضلة في أمريكا
في تلك العناصر اليومية مثل Twix و
Milky Way starbursts and Skitts ، لكن
من الأهمية بمكان جلب ابتكار جديد
على طول الطريق الذي تعمل به مجموعة البحث والتطوير في علماء الطعام لدينا
عن كثب لتحديد
الاتجاهات حقًا  أفضل مثال على القيام
بذلك هو لعبة البولنج الزومبي ، حيث كان
الإلهام الرئيسي للزومبي هو جلب
الإثارة والمتعة مرة أخرى إلى الهالوين ،
حيث يستمتع عملاؤنا
بها حقًا ويتجرأون على بعضهم البعض لمعرفة ما إذا كان
بإمكانهم الحصول على نكهة الزومبي الإجمالية وما إذا كان
بإمكانهم ذلك.  احتفظ بها في أفواههم عندما
تصل إلى المراحل الأخيرة من عيد الهالوين ، فإن
أهم العناصر هي كيفية ظهور
منتجاتك في متجر الحلويات ،
وهي فئة دافعة إلى حد كبير ولكن
المواسم مخططة لذلك من
المهم للغاية التأكد
من توفر المنتج
لدينا.  تحدثت إلى تجار التجزئة لدينا حول المكان
الذي تضع فيه العناصر الأكثر مبيعًا حيث
تضع موقع العرض
مهمًا حقًا  أفضل العقارات في
الواجهة الأمامية من المتجر ، هذه هي
العقارات الرئيسية في المتجر عندما تنظر
إلى الشاشة لديك
أصفر منارة تجذب المستهلكين إلى
الوجهة التي نستخدم فيها شخصيات M&M
المميزة لدينا لدينا أفضل مظهر  منزل
على الكتلة ولدينا نقاط سعر متعددة
تريد إزعاج المستهلك
أثناء دخوله بعربة فارغة
وفرصة لزيادة التحويل